بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد ف درسنا موصول
في قراءتنا ودراستنا ل سوره الرعد السوره
الثالث عشره من كتاب
الله وهي سوره
مكيه و عامه معاني هذه
السوره تدور
على توحيد الذي ارسل به النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه
وسلم
وهذا التوحيد ما هو والشرك الذي جاء
بالنهي
عنه والامثله
المضروبه واثار هذا القران العظيم على
قلوب
البشر
الران
قران
صح صلى الله عليه وسلم
مكه كما ذكرنا هذه السوره
مكيه والمكي
والمدني في كلام العلماء علماء
التفسير تعبير
منهم عن الوقت عن الزمن ليس عن
المكان يقولون سوره
مكيه اشاره الى الزمن المكي العهد المكي
قبل هجره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ويقولون صوره
مدنيه اي بعد هجرته الى المدينه
في العهد
المدني فليس هذا اشاره الى
المكان بل الى الزمان هذا العهد المكي ما
كان قبل الهجره والعهد المدني ما كان بعد
الهجره بغض النظر عن المكان
الذي انزلت هذه السوره
فيه يعني مثلا سوره
المائده سوره المائده سوره مدنيه باجماع
العلماء اين انزلت سوره المائده انزلت في
مكه في حجه
الوداع اذا هذه الصوره انزلت في مكه لكنها
مدنيه عند العلماء باجماع
وهذا هو
الراجح الذي عليه
غالب
المفسرين رحمهم الله تعالى قديما
وحديثا ان المكي والمدني ليس اشاره الى
الزمان ليس اشاره الى المكان وانما اشاره
الى
الزمان يقول تعالى الم لام م
را الم لام ميم هذه
الحروف هذه الحروف قد سبق ذكرها والتفصيل
فيها وذكرنا ان الم لام م الم لام م ص الم
لام م ر هذه الحروف كلها الحروف الهجاء
المقطعه في اوائل السور ليس لها معنى في
لغه العرب وانما لها مغزى في لغه العرب
وذلك
كانه يقول الم لام ميم راء هذه الحروف
التي
تستعملونها بلغتكم ايها الفصحاء
لكنكم وان كانت هذه الحروف في وسعكم وا
استطاعتكم الا انكم لن تاتوا بقران مثل
هذا فانه منظوم
نظما لا يستطيع احد من
العالمين تلك ايات الكتاب اي هذه الايات
هي ايات القران وايات من شريعه الله والذي
انزل اليك من ربك
الحق لماذا اكثر الناس لا يصدقون بهذا
الحق يقول ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون ليس
عيبا فيما انزل اليك وانما العيب في الناس
فانهم يتبعون اهوائهم بغير هدى من الله
فلذلك لا يؤمنون به وقد قال الله تعالى في
غير ما ايه لا يؤمنون به حتى يروا العذاب
الاليم
حينئذ لما يذهب عنهم
غاشيه الهوى
والشهوه
فانهم يقولون بما تكنه صدور
الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير عمد
ترونها يعني ليس لها عمد اصلا والعمد جمع
عماد والعماد
والاسطوانه التي نسميه
نحن بالعمود لكن العماد هو ما يكون
في يكون من
ركن في
وسط او على
اطراف
المبنى يقوم عليه
السقف
وهذا ال وهذه الاعمده ليست موجوده يقول
سبحانه وتعالى بغير عمد ترونها هذه
السماوات العظيمه رفعها الله سبحانه
وتعالى رفع
سمكها و ليس
لها
عمد هذا من عظيم
و بليغ صنع الله يقول تعالى صنع الله الذي
اتقن كل
شيء
فهذه السماوات رفعها الله سبحانه وتعالى
بغير
عمد ثم استوى على
العرش وقل وقد ذكرنا سابقا ان هذه ادله
على ماذا ليست ادله ليس مقصود الايات
الاستدلال على وجود الصانع على وجود
الخالق هذا كان شيء مفروغ منه عند
العرب لم يكونوا لينكر وجود الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولئن سالته من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن الله الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض ما عندهم اي نقاش في هذا ولو جاء
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بدعوتي ان امنوا
بوجود الله امنوا كلهم قاطبه ما كان في اي
مشكله المشكله وين المشكله ما كانت
في امنوا بوجود الخالق العرب كانوا يؤمنون
بوجود
الخالق وما كان احد منهم فيما ي رف ولا
يحد عن العرب كان منهم احد ينكر وجود
الخالق ممكن
يكون يعني بعض المجانين في الوديان يحكوا
كلام مثل هذا لكن شعرائهم
وراهم يمن
بذ
والرب كانب الاصنام ليس لانهم يزعمون ان
ثم خالقا مع الله وانما كما قال تعالى ما
نعبدهم الا ليقربونا الى الله
زلفه وكانوا يقولون في
الحج لبيك اللهم لبيك لبيك لا شريك لك
لبيك الا شريكا ملكته وما ملك هيك كان
يقول
فجاء النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم فعد
التلبيه وجعلها لا شريك
لك لا في العباده ولا في الخلق ولا في
الرزق ولا
في
اذا الايات في القران التي فيها الله الذي
رفع السماوات بغير عمد
ترونها الله سبحانه وتعالى ليس يدلل هنا
على وجود الخالق للعرب لان المستمع مقر
بان الخالق هو
الله
وانما ي يدلل على ان هذا الخالق
الذي انتم
تعترفون بانه الخالق الواحد الاحد
والرازق سبحانه وتعالى المدبر
الوحيد فاذا اعبدوه وحده
لا تعبد معه
غيره هذا هو التوحيد الذي جاءت به
الرسل اين موضع النزاع موضع النزاع ما كان
في وجود الخالق ولا كان في وجود احد يخلق
مع الخالق ما كان عندهم نقاش في هذا
وانما في العباده اعبدوا الله
وحده
ما يقول
اباؤكم هنا كانت كان النزاع بين الانبياء
قاطبه نادر جدا ان ياتي احد من الناس
و ينازع في وجود الخالق لماذا لان وجود
الخالق هذا الشيء مرتكز في
الفطره هذا شيء فطر الله الناس
عليه الناس فطره يمون ان لهم
خالق لكن لما انتكست الفطره في مثل هذه
الازمنه
المتاخره
اصبح الناس يتون في ذلك لذلك جاء في بعض
الروايات التي تدل على اخبار النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم عما سياتي في الغيب
فقال لا يزال الناس
يسالون
حتى يقولوا هذا الله خلق كل شيء فمن خلق
الله هكذا جاء في الحديث
يعني هذا شيء سياتي في اخر الزمانه الشيء
مستغرب كان غريب جدا على اسماع الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم
والفرس كانوا يؤمنون ب
خالقين خالق الشر
وهو خالق الظلام وخالق الخير وهو خالق
النور لكن مع اثبات ذلك كانوا يعترفون ان
خالق الخير خير من خالق الشر اذا ايش
معناه هذا الكلام في الا خالق واحد مش
ممكن يكون
في اثنين يخلقون ويدبرون ويتصرفون نفس
التصرف ونفس القوه تماما مستح
محيل ف وكذلك اليونان والروم بعض زناد
كانوا نعم ينكرون وجود الخالق سبحانه
وتعالى ولذلك تجد اكثر ادله اليونان
وفلسفه اليونان في اثبات ايش ما هو في
اثبات الوهيه الله وعباده الله اكثر
فلسفتهم في اثبات وجود خالق
لانه كان عندهم هذا المرض لكن هذا كان شيء
مستغرب وشيء اجنبي على على العرب في جزيره
العرب فهو يقول ثم استوى على العرش وسخر
الشمس والقمر كل يجري لاجل
مسمى ‏l مم را these are individual
letters which come at the begin as a
kind of prelude to many of the verses of
the قران many of the chapters of the
qu and these letter they ch from
different chapters some chapters with ال
را chapters ال مم some chapters with
aular letter
‏chapters they begin with these letters
and these letters are chos very
meticulously for very reas
however the general reas that all these
letter are
the
قران
قر الله سبحانه
وتعالى
translat are
veres legation الله سبحانه
وتالى
leg given
apri to
each
‏props he says and that has sent down to
you from your lord mean all that which
has been sent down to you from your lord
it is the
truth yet most people do not believe
most people do not believe not because
the truth is insufficient not because
what come to
froment they do not because people
‏objec most people are driven objec
people are driven by
subjectivity he then go on into the
second ver say
الله is the one who has raised the
heavens without any
pillars
now this raising of the heavens without
any pillars this does
not these are not
‏us ver
قران the
existence a creator they are actually
very
few meaning verses which were in
asic
‏bel
bel
existence of a the reason that they are
so few is
that these
verses are few the قران for the simp re
that arab time propet صل الله عليه وسلم
they aged and
con ‏without any partners they believed
in this the problem that they had was
not in affirming the existence of allah
the exist of a creator the problem that
they had was in
affirming worship of allah alone
without any partn that is where
they and that is that they did not
worship allah alone they worshiped allah
and they worshiped along with him other
سبحانه
وتالى صل الله عليه وسلم
قران
ag you age who raised the heav
الله
created
did why
wor
قران يقول تعالى ثم استوى على العرش
ثم حرف
عطف حرف
عطف
وهذا يدل على ترتيب ما بعدها على ما
قبلها ترتيب ما بعد ثم على ما قبل
ثم ترتيب
زمني وقد
يكون بين الاثنين تراخ في الزمن يعني اذا
قال الانسان
جاء خالد ثم
عمر يعني يفهم العربي ان خالد جاء وبعد ما
انتهى من مجيئه جاء عمر بعده هذا ترتيب
لكن لا يفهم منه
الترتيب بدون تراخي يعني ممكن يكون جاء
خالد وبعده بايام جاء عمر ممكن ممكن يكون
جاء بعده يعني مباشره ممكن يكون جاء بعده
تراخ في الزمن لكن
ثم هذا حرف يدل على الترتيب
الزمني فقوله تعالى ثم استوى على
العرش استوى في لغه
العرب اي ارتفع وعلى على العرش والعرش
مخلوق عظيم خلقه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
و
العرش كان
موجودا قبل خلق السماوات
والارض الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول وكان عرشه
على
الماء يعني خلق السماوات والارض وكان عرشه
على الماء طيله هذا الزمن والعلماء
اختلفوا هل السماوات
والارض خلقت اولا ثم العرش ام العرش اولا
ام
الماء لانه يقول وكان عرشه على
الماء خلاف بين العلماء
لكن جاء في بعض الروايات في السنن ان
جماعه من اليمن جاؤوا الى النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم فسالوه قالوا يا رسول الله
جئناك نسالك عن اول هذا
الامر فقال صلى الله عليه
وسلم اول ما خلق الله القلم فقال له اكتب
قال ما اكتب قال اكتب ما هو كائن الى يوم
القيامه
فخلق سبحانه وتعالى
القلم ثم
خلق السماوات
والارض يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم وكان ذلك
قبل خلق السماوات والارض
ب00
سنه هذا حديث
صحيح و قد يفهم منه ان القلم تقدم خلقه
على العرش
لكن هذا الاستدلال فيه نظر
لماذا
لان هؤلاء هذه المجموعه التي جاءت من
اليمن تسال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
اول هذا الامر يعني هذا الخلق هذا
السماوات والارض و خلق البشر وال الامور
كما نراها ايش اول هذه الاشياء فاول هذه
الاشياء
القلم
لكن
العرش هو كان
موجودا قبل خلق القلم حتى وهذا العرش
استوى الله سبحانه وتعالى عليه هل نفهم
معاني هذه
الكلمات يعني
المعنى
نحن نفرق بين المعنى
والكيفيه الكيفيه
والمعنى قد يفهم الانسان المعنى ولا يفهم
الكيفيه هذا وارد قد يفهم المعنى ويفهم
الكيفيه يعني لو قلت
مثلا لبست الثوب لب الثوب تفهمون المعنى
وتفهمون
الكيفيه لانكم بشر مثلي وتعلمون كيف يلبس
الثوب فتفهم المعنى وتفهمون
الكيفيه لكن
لوت
ل جماعه من العرب قبل 1000 سنه التقيت
معهم وقلت لهم
نطير في
الهواء في الطائره عندنا طائرات
ونطير
ونقطع
المسافات العظيمه في ساعات
قليله يفهمون المعنى اليس كذلك يفهمون
المعنى هل يفهمون الكيفيه لا يفهمون ولا
يعقلون الكيفيه
اصلا ليس لهم مثل سابق مثال سابق لهم او
ليس لهم ممارسه في هذه الامور حتى يفهمون
حتى يفهموا
الكيف فالمعنى
مفهوم ويصدقون بالمعنى اذا كنت صادقا
عندهم اذا كنت انا موضع الثقه عندهم
يقولون
نعم في المستقبل او الاجيال القا قادمه
سيطير في الهواء ويقطعون المسافات العظيمه
في ساعات
قليله فيقال لهم كيف يفعلون ذلك فيقولون
الله
اعلم نحن نصدق هذا الكلام لان الثقه
اخبرنا به اليس كذلك صحيح النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم هو الصادق المصدوق لما اخبر
الصحابه
باشياء هي حتى
لنا
انزالها على عقولنا صعب ليس من باب المعنى
وانما من باب الكيفيه يعني لما اخبر
الصحابه ان
الرجل سيعود الى بيته
وتحدثه او ويحدثه فخذه بما صنع اهله
شو
فخذه يحدثه بما صنع اهله في غيابه
والعصى
و الشيء يخبره بما صنع اهله الصحابه هل
فهموا معاني هذه الكلام فهموا المعاني
المعنى
مفهوم لكن
كيفيه وقوع هذه الامور هل كانت معروفه لدى
الصحابه ليست
معروفه لما اخبر ان الدجال ياتي على
الارض
و ياتي على الارض
كالغيث يستدبر الريح سرعه على
الارض وياتي على كل بقعه من بقع الارض الا
مكه والمدينه ولا
يترك مكانا ولا قريه الا يدخلها الا مكه
والمدينه واخبر بالاشياء التي
تكون هل نحن مع تقدمنا
الان نفهم جميع معاني هذه
الاشياء نفهم
المعنى لكن الكيفيه الكيفيه غير
واضح الكيفيه غير واضحه
لنا يعني ياتي واول يوم كسنه 40 يوم واول
يوم كسنه وثاني يوم كشهر وثالث يوم كاسبوع
وبقيه الايام
كايام نحن نفهم المعنى هل نفهم الكيف
الشمس تطلع من مغربها في اخر الزمان نفهم
المعنى اليس كذلك هل نفهم الكيف لا نفهم
الكيفيه عدم فهم كيفيه الشيء لا يمنع من
فهم معنى الشيء ولا يلزم منه الجاهل
الجاهل ماذا يفعل يخلط بين الكيف والمعنى
بصير يخبص
بينهم فاذا لم يفهم
الكيف اول المعنى وحرف
المعنى حتى يستقيم مع الكيفيه التي هو
يعرفها وهذا هو عين الج
كيف هذا الكلام يعني
مثلا اذا قلنا
اي اذا رجعنا على المثل
الاول نرجع على جماعه قبل 1000 سنه من
العرب قول لهم يا جماعه احنا في المستقبل
بنطير عننا اشياء اسمها طيارات بنطير فيهن
من مكان الى مكان
في زمن قصير جدا
واهلهم
جر بيجي واحد لا يفهم الكيفيه هم يفهمون
المعنى لكن لا يفهمون
الكيفيه فلا يثبتون المعنى يقولون نحن
نفهم المعنى ولا نفهم الكيف والله اعلم
بالكيف لكن اخبرنا الثقه فنبت هذا هو
الصحيح وال
السليم لكن لو جاؤوا وقالوا
هذا شيء غير
معقول هذا الطيران وما شابه ذلك هذه
خرافات وانما
المقصود ليس انهم يطيرون حسا وانما
معنا يجعلون الجن يتناقلون
اخبارهم والا فهم لا ينتقلون من مكان الى
مكان وانما هم سحره كل الناس سحره في اخر
الزمان هل هذا هل هذا التفكير صحيح وسليم
طبعا لا هذا غلط وخطا
كبير وايش الحامل عليه الخلط بين الكيفيه
والمعنى اثبات المعنى لا يستلزم اثبات
الكيفيه او فهم المعنى لا يستلزم فهم
الكيفيه ممكن افهم المعنى ما افهم الكيف
ولله المثل الاعلى اذا الله سبحانه وتعالى
انزل لنا في كتابه بلسان عربي مبين ثم
استوى على
العرش يجي واحد يقول ثم استولى على العرش
غلط هذا تحريف
للكلام لان الاستلاء
الاستيلاء معنى
والاستواء هذا شيء حسي هذا شيء
ا
يفعله الفاعل
فالله سبحانه وتعالى استوى على العرش يعني
على على العرش
حقيقه كيف استوى على العرش لا
ندري لا ندري كيف استوى الله سبحانه
وتعالى على العرش
نعلم انه استوى معنى استوى على العرش
فماذا نصنع عند
هذه عند هذا الموضع من الفهم نثبت
المعنى ونفوض
الكيفيه نقول الكيفيه الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى واما المعنى
نثبته ينزل الله في اخر ثلث من كل ليله
فيقول هل من
سائل
فاعطيه هل من مستغفر فاغفر له هل من تائب
فاتوب
عليه هذه معاني واضحه صح ولا لاكل كل عربي
يفهم هذه المعاني حتى على زمن 1500 سنه
بتغير اللسان العربي وتطوره ما زالت هذه
المعاني مفهومه لكل عربي في كل مكان
والكيفيه هل هي معقوله كيف ينزل الله في
اخر ثلث من الليل حتى الناس ما عندهم حدود
في سؤال في سؤالهم ما عنده حد المفروض
الانسان يكون له حد حد في السؤال من الادب
مع الله سبحانه
وتعالى
فالانسان لا يشبه الله سبحانه وتعالى
بنفسه ويقول لو كنت انا سانزل في اخر ثلث
من
الليل لكانت تعتريني المشكله التاليه
الاخر الثلث من الليل متنقل وانا ما
استطيع اكون في كل مكان فاذا انا دائما
اكون متنقله هذا تفكير فيه تشبيه تشبيه
الخالق بالمخلوق هذه تشكل على المخلوق لا
تشكل على الخالق سبحانه وتعالى وهو ليس
كمثله
شيء اذا نحن نثبت المعاني واما الكيفيه
هذه نفوض بامرها الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
‏disc the
time
second س
الر قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله without
any pillar without any pill ‏you can see
and then he rose above the throne
statement he rose above the
throne what does this mean meaning is
very clear there is no language in which
this meaning is unclear the arabic
language rose above the throne is clear
every langage understands
meaning
‏just for instance we know of
certain things even we have experien for
instance infinity that has no end we
know the me we the mean inf we the
mean
الله has no begin and he has no end we
know the
meats we do not know the how of these
things we don't know the physical
descriptions or
the the reality of these things we
understand the meanings of the hereafter
we understand the meanings that there
hellfire and paradise and the nature of
these two places is such and such we
understand these things ‏we do not
understand how these things ex how they
are we don't understand them even though
these things are creation they are the
creation of just we are the
creation
of they are beyond our realm
understanding why because we don't have
any
experience in our lives in our past to
be able
to our
‏we
relent that how is know الله سبحانه
وتالى
instance الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏he created from nothing something
how did this
happen we will never understand that
human
beings we understand the meaning of that
correct yes the meaning is understood
the how
absolutely a mystery to us totally mys
us we don't
know there are many things that never
know and
so when it comes to
الله
الله understand me
things all قران as for the how how these
things ur how these things ex these are
things الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏we we we
r
r and
me how
الله
الله الله سبحانه
وتى any
any how does create how
does etern life how does have no
beginning and end these are things which
are a total mystery to the human being
we believe them
because
us
‏us and we
says and all attribut all
action الله سبحانه وتعالى him this is
the same equation the same formula that
we use in order
to adhere to
believing us
and
b سبحانه
وتع والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين